Як правило, ці мої подорожі продовжуються на метрів 200, де нещодавно зробили спуск.
Ось такі забіги з перепонами Сергій Храпко долає щодня, виїжджаючи з дому на своєму "танчику", як він називає свій електричний інвалідний візок.
Голосіївський район, де мешкає Сергій, відносно новий, але за кожне рішення щодо безбар'єрності йому доводилося боротися.
У перші роки (інвалідності) самостійно я не виїжджав взагалі. Не роки, напевно, рік, тому що перепони на кожному кроці.
Це не дивно і не було дивиною ні для кого ні раніше, ні зараз. Тим більше самостійне пересування, особливо без електровізка.
Воно як мінімум дуже важко, а іноді небезпечно.
Сергій - ветеран АТО. У 2015 році він брав участь у боях на Світлодарській дузі, де потрапив під мінометний обстріл.
У результаті чоловік втратив ліві руку й ногу. Через повномасштабне вторгнення Росії людей з інвалідністю в Україні стає дедалі більше.
Тому, переконаний Сергій, міські простори мають активніше враховувати їхні потреби.
Треба розуміти - цивільних багато, військових забагато, дуже багато ампутацій рук, ніг різного ступеня складності.
Запит величезний. Це і раніше було непросто. А зараз взагалі не знаю, як це буде відбуватися.
На запит DW у КМДА відповіли, що про інклюзивність памʼятають і роблять, що можуть - відповідно до "наявного фінансування".
Наприклад, зазначається, що київські комунальники "вживають заходи щодо пониження бортового каменю на наземних пішохідних переходах".
Депутатка Київської міської ради Ксенія Семенова подала на розгляд проєкт,
який має зобов‘язати КМДА пришвидшити роботу над безбар‘єрним середовищем.
Депутатка зокрема пропонує дублювати підземні і надземні переходи наземними.
Це допомогло би маломобільним людям переходити дорогу, не використовуючи сходи.
На думку Сергія Храпка, саме високі бордюри й відсутність пандусів - це основні перепони в місті.
За його словами, у Києві досі багато громадських місць абсолютно не пристосовані до потреб людей з інвалідністю.
Парк Рильського - там одні запитання. Там відповідей немає взагалі. Там просто людині на візку взагалі апріорі неможливо подолати його
- ні вздовж, ні впоперек, ніяким чином взагалі. Там є невеличкі нюанси, де місцями щось там робилося в минулому році. Але це точково якось...
Експерт з планування міського простору Тимофій Нагірний вже давно займається питаннями безбар'єрності Києва.
На думку урбаніста, такі речі треба одразу закладати в проєкти планування, бо виправити те, що вже збудовано, складніше і дорожче.
От ми в центрі столиці. І саме цей перехід - він будувався тоді, коли будували вулицю Скоропадського, 2001 рік. Тоді ніхто не думав про жодну інклюзивність,
коли будувався цей Бессарабський квартал. Тому тут такий рельєф, що дуже складно впровадити саме пішохідний перехід.
До списку заходів з інклюзивності на порядку денному КМДА - також громадський транспорт.
У мерії звітують: "станом на грудень 2021 року на балансі підприємства перебувають 601 автобусів, 357 тролейбусів, 100 трамвайних вагонів,
які повноцінно пристосовані для перевезення осіб з інвалідністю". Проте, за словами Сергія, на практиці такий транспорт функціонує не так, як хотілося б.
Я безмежно щасливий, що в нас є автобуси, наприклад, з низькою платформою. Але я був би значно щасливіший, якби вони працювали.
Як правило, там чи не працює ця відкидна штука, чи там, не знаю, у водія болять руки. Там купа відмазок буває.
Але, як правило, маючи автобуси з відкидною платформою, ти не завжди маєш змогу заїхати в нього.
На думку Сергія, єдиний вид транспорту, який відносно непогано адаптовано до потреб маломобільних людей, - це метро.
Там людям на візках допомагають співробітники. Щоправда, за даними самої ж КМДА,
з 52-х столичних станцій метро лише 13 "повністю пристосовані для пересування осіб з інвалідністю та інших маломобільних груп населення".
На думку урбаніста Тимофія Нагірного, столицю України все ще не можна назвати комфортною для маломобільних людей.
Невеликі зрушення є, але щоб відчутно поліпшити ситуацію необхідні системні, а не точкові рішення.
Треба просто не боятися їх впроваджувати насамперед. Це кому треба робити? Міській владі.
Активісти підкажуть, але вони не можуть самі зробити. Активісти не є проєктантами. Вони не є управлінцями.
Депутатка Ксенія Семенова погоджується, що на КМДА має тиснути громадське суспільство.
А депутати Київради мають подавати і затверджувати більше проєктів щодо інклюзивності.
Пріоритети столиці продемонструє бюджет на наступний рік.
Складне питання із бюджетуванням. Тобто на етапі розподілу бюджету на наступний рік це повинно обов'язково з'явитися.
І я буду це для себе розуміти як індикатор успіху цієї затії взагалі. Тому що вирішити, що так, ми дублюємо підземні переходи наземними, можна.
Але далі питання, скільки таких дубльованих переходів закладеться в бюджет на наступний рік.
Попри всі складнощі, з якими стикається Сергій, він не хоче відчувати себе жертвою обставин.
Чоловік займається спортом, водить дітей до школи, працює.
На думку військового, проблеми маломобільних людей стосуються всіх киян, а не лише людей з інвалідністю.
Я вважаю, що це не стосується лише безпосередньо ветеранів як таких або інвалідів саме військових -
для цього великого розуму не треба. Люди з дитячим візком навіть не можуть піднятися - ось у чому питання.
Це в першу чергу образа людей в цілому має бути. Тому що не може підняти ноги бабця в сімдесят років на ту сходинку.
Яка різниця, хто на неї піднімає ногу? Ветеран чи бабця?
За словами урбаністів, в інших українських містах, особливо маленьких, ситуація з безбар'єрністю та інклюзією ще гірша.
І завдання держави - подбати, щоб люди з обмеженнями у пересуванні - цих обмежень не відчували.